non-minimalists
all right how do we unsubscribe from a
whole bunch of email subscriptions at
one time
is this possible i didn't know you could
do that it is so there is a service
called unroll me okay unroll dot me you
can do it with physical mail for sure i
have to do that like once every two or
three years because yes something
happens to where like and it works
really really well yeah stop getting all
the spam
you know yeah i'll pull that up as well
we can talk about that real quick
because the minimalists.com
day 15. so we've got this 21 day journey
on our website the first thing we ever
published at the minimalists way back in
2010
so it all started yes yes indeed so
at the bottom of day 15 the direct
marketing association offers a free
online only service at dmacc.org to stop
catalogs and junk mail deliveries
or to get more of them if you desire
you imagine like oh i'm gonna sign up
for more junk mail right
but you can
most legit mailers are a member of the
dma so this could reduce your load of
unsolicited mail by up to two-thirds
when you're at the dma site you may also
see a direct link to
optoutprescreen.com which will prevent
the majority of major credit bureaus
from sending pre-approved credit card
applications to you another site you'll
want to check out is
worldprivacyforum.org
which is a clearinghouse for all these
matters so you just go to the
minimalist.com day 15. you can find
those there's one other thing i'd add to
this now i use an app on my phone i
think it cost me two bucks a month it's
called uh paper karma oh yeah and so
anytime i get who gets mail anymore by
the way who what the hell are we doing
dude i get mail from the people who used
to live i still get a gas bill from them
like for the people who used to live
right and i like i'm calling the gas
company return to sender like it's it
drives me insane anyway you're getting
everyone else's mail or everyone else is
junk they want to thrust upon you yeah
there's one exception though so we
actually encourage people to write
letters to us oh yeah so you can mail us
here at the studio anything handwritten
is always a delight to get in the mail
right but that's not usually what we get
in the mail no everything we get in the
mail are things we don't want oh my god
and they do such a good job of like you
get the mail and it feels it looks
important looks official like some kind
of tax document or something yes and
then you open it up and it's like you
could get directv for 44.99 a month
right yeah and it makes it look like
urgent open now yeah but in a way or
sometimes they'll even make it look like
it's hand written
and it tricks me and i'm like oh maybe
my cousin sent me i don't know something
anyway
i almost never at home get mail that i
want right i'm sure
occasionally i'll get something that is
like the paris review which is a
quarterly
uh review that i subscribe to fiction
and poetry and stuff like that but i
have to surf through an entire tidal
wave of junk of nonsense
and the way that i've opted out of most
of it 90 plus percent or the things i
just talked about the minimalists.com
day 15. it really works too yeah
absolutely does yeah this is we don't
sell anything there it's not ours it's
just in fact that information is from
clark howard and and then on top of that
i used paper karma so anytime i get some
sort of solicitation from state farm or
something you just snap a photo of it
and it picks out where it comes from and
they automatically unsubscribe you wow
but let's talk about email on top of
this as well yeah so well
i was gonna say one more thing about uh
junk mail it what blows my mind is how
much
of the mail that gets sent how much of
it is advertisements yes like it's got
to be 80 or 85
so it just makes me think how i've seen
you know congress like come up with
these bills these these laws that say
hey we don't want to do junk mail
anymore we just had it like last year
where they wanted to stop the robo
dialing but the problem is that there's
so much money
and the people who provide the service
to send junk mail or the people who
provide the service and the robo calls
that they don't do the right thing yeah
or the courteous thing maybe especially
with respect to
the junk mail because it's the post
office their main function is to spam
your mailbox it's yeah it's really wild
when you look at it that way in terms of
their revenue the vast majority of their
revenue comes from junk
we call it junk mail
and yet there are some ways to obviously
deal with it we talked about those let's
move over to email because it's even
easier to get junk mail there people
spam you or
over time you just signed up for a bunch
of newsletters you bought something from
this company and they enrolled you on
their list or you signed up for a
newsletter that you no longer want now
there used to be this site well there
still is a site called unroll.me
but there were some issues with that so
i've got this article here i'll put a
link to it in the show notes for this
maximal episode by the way if you want
to write a letter to us it's
theminimalists.com
contact we will check those letters
anyway this is from b-bomb
and the
title is six the six best unroll.me
alternatives you can use
unroll.me is a powerful tool that helps
you unsubscribe from unwanted emails and
keeps your inbox
clutter free however the track record of
this popular service when it comes to
respecting users privacy is questionable
to say the least back in 2017 a new york
times report exposed the company's
privacy practices that showed how it
shared user data with uber hence if
you're looking for alternatives to
unroll me here are our best picks wow so
like they were the website under the
guise of we're gonna help you get less
junk mail
and then they just collected people's
information and sold it off that's how
they made money yes and so keep in mind
if you're using something for free
you are the product yes and that's why
i'm always happy to pay for something
like paper karma for example because
it's like it's two bucks
but they're also i'm not the product now
i'm actually buying the product and i
use it regularly so number one the
built-in unsubscribe button this isn't a
third-party tool but is the simplest way
to unscribe unsubscribe from emails when
you see a promotional email or a
newsletter that no longer interests you
click the unsubscribe button at the top
of gmail outlook or other email services
of your choice
etc etc number two is leave me alone
that sounds like the perfect app for me
leave me alone ryan
you wish a great alternative to
unroll.me
is leave me alone with this website you
can easily unsubscribe from all unwanted
emails you have to create an account on
leave me alone to use this service
through the free tier you get a total of
five on subscriptions so this is a free
a freemium model and then you have to
pay two dollars of 50 cents for 50
unsubscribes 10 bucks a month for 50
unsubscribes per month or 16 a month for
200 unsubscribes a month dude i
i donated once to a political candidate
worst decision i've ever done in my life
same because it's like then you get like
oh hi i'm john smith and i need your
help and then you're like you don't
subscribe from john smith but then you
get you know sally cute i mean like it
just it's never-ending it's the worst
it has incentivized me to never donate
oh yeah every time i unsubscribe and
like when i put a reason i'm like it's
because
you send me so you don't respect my
inbox yes like that's why i'm
unsubscribing and oh by the way yeah you
have basically made it so i will never
donate to any political candidate ever
again yeah thanks for disrespecting my
time my attention and even the money i
gave you i paid you to spam me how
ridiculous is that yeah number three is
unlister for outlook so if you use
outlook there is if you're looking for a
tool built
especially for outlook unlister should
be your pick the service will scan your
inbox for spammy emails and will list
them all out for you so it sort of gives
you a list all you have to do is click
on the unsubscribe button
with a free trial you can unsubscribe
for up to five email email lists or you
pay 20 bucks a year to get complete
access number four is polymail
unsubscriber it is a tool
another option you may consider if
you're looking for an easy solution to
unsubscribe from emails for those of you
who don't know polymail is an email
client for pc
okay and then number five clean fox
another third party solution that might
come in handy is clean fox just like
other services on this list you'll have
to link your email account to access and
use the service from clean fox's
homepage you can either delete an
unwanted email or delete and unsubscribe
from the sender altogether so you can do
either one there and then finally there
is a
service called clean email lastly we
have clean email clean email is a
helpful service for those looking for a
way to regain control over their inbox
you can use clean email's unsubscriber
feature to stop receiving unsubscribed
emails however it is a paid feature good
i'm i'm great because here's the thing
if you're not paying for it you're gonna
get advertised to or they're just
collecting your data so you can be
careful with all of these are
alternatives i'm not saying don't use
unroll.me i don't know maybe their track
record has gotten much better since they
were exposed by the new york times i'm
wondering ryan with the recent
flurry of spam that you've you've had
take over your inbox maybe something you
can do is try one of these out we can
report back on a future maximal episode
over here on patreon i would love to try
it out did you enjoy this video if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free